Well Middle Light is the latest beer
brand facing a stunning backlash for a
man-bashing ad the U.S beer famously
used Playboy models in his signature
campaigns throughout the 90s and early
2000s Megan Markle of course went on to
be a suitcase girl on Deal or No Deal
front of this ad for the brand in 2010
but the new commercial strikes are
rather different tone
here's a little known fact women were
among the very first to brew beer ever
from Mesopotamia to the Middle Ages to
colonial America women were the ones
doing the Brewing centuries later how
did the industry pay homage to the
founding mothers of beer they put us in
bikinis
look at this wild it's time beer made it
up to women so today Miller Lite is on a
mission to clean up not just their shop
the whole beer Industries
terrible aren't men awful awful women in
bikinis shocking who would have thought
any woman would have been in a bikini
admired by men I mean it's just the last
thing you'd be buying a bikini ball
right it's parent company has trashed
its own Brand's mud wrestling catfight
ad from 2003 in its defense saying women
shouldn't be forced to mud wrestle in
order to sell beer
why not I thought mud was good for the
skin
competitive Bud light's notorious
campaign featuring influencer Dylan
Mulvaney and so far cost the company
more than six million dollars in market
capitalization I think there's a six
billion actually um because uh actually
it turned out men didn't want to be told
that they're idiots and that actually
this beer was aimed at transgender women
who were biological males who are
pretending to be women
so are they using the power of
advertising to make a powerful and
Progressive social point to these
companies or just deliberately
self-harming themselves by alienating
their core customers I'm joined by
former Levi's brand president Jennifer
say legal journalist Ava Santino all
right well welcome to both of you
Jennifer say it seems to have been a run
of these kind of advers it goes back I
think to the Gillette Infamous Gillette
one in the wake of The metoo Campaign
which is a perfectly laudable campaign
I'm not knocking it at all but the
Gillette campaign that ran after it
which basically rather than celebrating
masculinity became a tirade of abuse
about effectively all men are awful
monsters unless they can prove otherwise
and Gillette lost I think nine billion
dollars off the bottom line until we did
a complete reverse ferret and went back
to celebrating masculinity again and
we're going to see the same thing with
Bud Light I expect we'll see the same
thing with with Miller Lite what is
going on here why are these companies
surrendering to this well what Elon Musk
would call the woke virus
to say the right thing well I would um
you know having been in the board rooms
and executive rooms for men a very long
time I would call it wolf washing
um it may be a cynical take but I can
tell you it is true these brands are
thinking if we align ourselves with the
perceived values of younger consumers
gen Z and Millennials
um they'll like us and they'll buy our
product we don't have to talk about
product benefit we'll just align
ourselves with their values so that we
can make money off of it
um and it's a it's a it's a virtue
signal to distance themselves from you
know past campaigns the greedy business
magnets of the past and it also serves
to conceal
um the last altruistic business
practices so it's a lie and that
shielding works the Press generally is
all in on it they're able to avoid
scrutiny from the Press by taking these
stances and they just don't think about
the fact that half the consumer base is
now not aligned they just aren't and
that insulting your consumer is is not
the way to go usually if you insult the
consumer they're going to reject the
product I'm not catching a gigantic
Financial call so here's my issue about
this what is wrong with using sexy women
and bikinis to sell beer well I think
actually your your commentator explained
it perfectly there you are alienating
half of your base this is why would a
woman find that offensive well hang on
this is a person who apparently was in
the boardroom for Levi but doesn't
understand that actually women are
consumers and perhaps maybe they are
going to now spend half of the business
you're not answering my question why why
would women be offended by attractive
women posing in bikinis to sell beer I'm
not offended by attractive women I am
offended by men over sexualizing women
and I you know what you know what it is
a lot of men can't control themselves a
lot of men think that if they buy that
beer they start wrestling I think it
celebrates Womanhood and it celebrates
the the beauty of mud which we all know
is good for the skin that's ridiculous
come on let's actually think what be
watching here what to do with beer why
am I going to buy this product I'm a bit
you know why because it was a joke and
there used to be a time pre-wokery uh
when you're allowed to just have a joke
the women were in on it the memory on it
everybody laughed nobody got offended
now people watch that kind of AD and
they literally go nuts they find
themselves being electrified in a
triggering manner they have to go and
hide in a safe space then they look
marches down Main busy thoroughfares
because of a joke what has happened to
that light hand on matilla why do we
care so much why are we now going to
expose men to all these adverts doing a
kind of reverse assault on us have you
considered that maybe it's not all about
men maybe they're actually a large
proportion of females that would like to
see adverts that don't include scans why
are Bud Light why is Bud Lights market
cap just disintegrated now that's that's
a different that's a different topic
altogether I think we could I think you
could see there is some Merit in we
don't need to sexualize women in order
to
you sexualize yourselves in lots of
women's magazines and indeed in men's
magazine I don't think I did anything of
the salt you may not done personally
it's only a matter of time now that
you're a television Superstar uh when
the money comes from GQ off I'm I'm not
saying you will I'm just saying normally
in my experience
that will happen and then that is up to
those men to buy those magazines and
perhaps if they'd like to peruse it they
can but it doesn't mean that women are
going to buy them if you go around the
High Street and look at women's
magazines there'll be lots of women in
bikinis and how unhealthy was that on a
whole generation of women no now yeah
how unhealthy is that why is it
unhealthy because it sparked a whole
generation nothing radiates good health
more than a very attractive fit woman in
a bikini no that's not rather like
rather like by the way the way that
women have for a very long time drooled
over good-looking men for example oh
that's totally different oh I don't
think so let's look at this wonderful
advert for Coke remember this
I don't want you to work all day
but I want you to be true
[Music]
just
just for make love to you
see you tomorrow 11 30.
love to you I Wanna Make Love to You Ava
I mean that at you I'm just repeating
what I've just seen in the advert which
is a bunch of women drooling oh and
there's more and you know what I don't
know let's watch some more
love to you
all I want to do is wash your clothes
I mean I kind of if I was a lawyer in a
court case it would be I have nothing
more to offer your honor I rest my case
I think you enjoyed that more than I did
you know why I did this
I enjoyed it because of the stinking
hypocrisy no that's ridiculous and by
the way because if those women I know
and I suspect you would be like this if
we were off camera in a pub somewhere
you would laugh at stuff like this it's
just we're now enforced because of this
woke virus to take all these things
incredibly seriously to be incredibly
offended no one's allowed to laugh no
one can find these things humorous no
one thinks that women can fancy men or
men fancy women it's all evil how do we
get so boring over are you joking I
don't know if you're actually doing no
I'm serious it's all about a power
Dynamic you must be able to see that
those women well those women about the
men they are playfully laughing and just
it's all a good joke and we're all in I
love the fact you're trying to defend
this thing about this I love them I love
the fact you're trying to draw some
distinction between what we're watching
here let me bring back Jennifer Jennifer
this to me just I'm afraid epitomizes
the rank double standard
I think there's something that is in
between where we're not objectifying
women and I would say to Bud Light out
it ran just a few months ago uh with
Miles Teller and his wife that had the
trademark Bud Light humor it was funny
it it demonstrated sort of an updated
view uh to masculinity and what it means
to be a man he's a good husband he's
Charming he's funny he's dancing with
his wife and she's not scantily clad
they're having fun together
um he's not sort of shoving her out of
the way to get to his beer so I I would
agree with you humor Works in
advertising why do we have to abandon
that why does it have to be so worthy
why do we get so prudish why can't we
just also enjoy the male and female form
we certainly can and I would say another
ad which you may be familiar with in the
80s one of Levi's most successful ads
that ran in the the UK featuring Nick
Cayman for 501 shrinks I don't know if
you remember this ad one of the most
successful of all time it's a it's a
good sort of analog to the to the diet
coke one you ran because it's funny it's
cheeky
um there's little ladies that they think
he looks cute when he takes his pants
off in the laundromat no one's
objectified it's funny but here's the
other thing of course he's being
objectified but nobody cares men don't
care what the product is at the center
this is the problem I'm not gonna buy
something because a female Brewer from
200 years ago made it why do I care you
know what if I saw a good if I saw a
good bit of mud wrestling on TV tomorrow
I go and buy that beer instinctively oh
principle just because it's so
refreshing to see an ad that was
actually a bit naughty a bit funny
that that that's fair I think bringing
humor back is is important I think
Jennifer honestly I think we have
forgotten how to love wokery is where
comedy goes to die and this is the
problem we've forgotten how to have fun
between the Sexes and just a lot have a
laugh little Saucy postcards on they'll
be coming for those next the ones on the
beach on the results they'll have to go
can't have jokes about things like sex
gotta leave it there thank you Ava thank
you Jennifer I appreciate it please can
we bring back some humor can we just go
back to having fun having a laugh
No One's Gonna Die it's all fine